[Musique]
les sénateurs agissent
comment améliorer le contrôle des ehpad
rationnement des repas mauvais
traitements après les révélations du
journaliste victor castanet dans son
livre les fossoyeurs sur les dérives du
groupe orpea au sein de plusieurs ehpad
en france famille salariés et syndicats
attendent des réponses
pour comprendre pourquoi les abus
constatés n'ont pas pu être empêché la
commission des affaires sociales a mis
en place une mission d'information axé
sur le contrôle de ces établissements
d'hébergement pour personnes âgées
dépendantes
les sénateurs bernard bonne et michel
meunier sont les rapporteur de cette
mission qui bénéficient des prérogatives
d'une commission d' enquête
au delà d'une réaction à l'actualité la
commission des affaires sociales
poursuit ainsi une réflexion à long
terme sur la prise en charge de nos
aînés
dès janvier 2021 constatant la
vulnérabilité accrue des résidents d pad
pendant la crise sanitaire la commission
avait sollicité une enquête auprès de la
cour des comptes sur leur prise en
charge médicale
cette enquête remise en février 2022
décrit un modèle à bout de souffle
malgré des dépenses publiques en
progression de 30% entre 2011 et 2010 9
fait inhabituel la cour des comptes
souhaite que soit engagé des dépenses
supplémentaires comprises entre 1,3 et
1,9 milliard d'euros par an
ces réflexions sont venus enrichir les
travaux de la mission sénatoriale
mardi 15 mars elle a commencé son cycle
d'auditions en recevant victor castanet
il était invité à apporter
éclaircissements et précision sur
plusieurs points de son enquête
michel meunier là par exemple interrogé
sur la fréquence des contrôles et sur
les liens entre les agences régionales
de santé et le groupe orpea
la mission d'information a ensuite
entendu des syndicats représentant les
corps d'inspection des ars les syndicats
des secteurs sanitaire et médico-social
et des directeurs d'agencés régionales
de santé
brigitte bourguignon ministre délégué
auprès du ministre des solidarités de la
santé et les dirigeants des groupes
orpea france et korian seront à leur
tour prochainement auditionné
pour en savoir plus consultez les
travaux de la mission d'information
[Musique]